la última hora son ataques en la región
de sap orilla en el sureste de ucrania
las autoridades de este país han
denunciado el lanzamiento de varios
misiles en esta zona donde está ubicada
la planta nuclear más grande de europa
hay que recordar que esta
infraestructura está bajo control ruso
desde el pasado mes de marzo y que este
incidente se produce después de las
palabras del ministro de exteriores de
rusia quien dijo que el peligro de una
guerra nuclear es real el incidente
asimismo confirma que la guerra continúa
aquí en el este de ucrania donde nos
encontramos esta mañana hemos visto a
aviones sobrevolar a escasa altitud y
también hay informaciones de avances de
las tropas rusas en algunos pueblos de
esta región así como de nuevos
enfrentamientos en summit en el noreste
del país la guerra se recrudece en esta
región y también se sigue cobrando la
economía de este país según los últimos
datos ucrania perderá al menos el 20 por
ciento de sus cosechas de granos este
año con respecto al año anterior
anterior y esto ocurre en el país que es
considerado el de europa